wenige Stunden nach den ja komplett
berührenden Szenen dort mit der ganzen
royal family in der Westminster Hall
der zusammen Kind
Charlie eine Harmonie also zumindest
müssen sie jetzt harmonisch erstmal bis
zum kommenden Montag und hier hier
können wir einmal ins Gesicht schauen
ich war ja besonders interessiert daran
was sich bei Meghan so abspielt ich
finde bei Kate sieht man tiefe Trauer
und bei Meghan eine gewisse Unsicherheit
das ist nur meine eigene Interpretation
aber die große Frage ist natürlich die
fat4 William Kate Harry und Meghan wie
lange wird dieser Frieden halten
im trauervereint nach der Bitte von
König Charles zeigen sich jetzt die
Brüder William mit Kate und Harry mit
Meghan endlich wieder vereint beim
Trauerzug durch Windsor Castle nehmen
die Royals Abschied von Elisabeth II
teilen ihre Gefühle mit den Menschen die
Royals sind mit ihrem Volk vereint es
herrscht eine menschliche liebevolle
Stimmung die entspannte Atmosphäre zeigt
sich mit den Trauernden im Gespräch
okay wurde gesagt
[Musik]
sie trösten die Menschen sprechen mit
ihnen tauschen sich aus die jungen
Royals ganz menschlich nehmen sich Zeit
zeigen sich volksnah in trauerverein
nehmen die Geschwister Abschied von
ihrer geliebten Großmutter bleibt die
Hoffnung dass die Brüder William und
Harry sich weiterhin annähern und sich
eine Stütze sind vielleicht braucht er
es den Tod der Queen um sich wieder zu
versöhnen
William und Harry dieser Royale Frieden
wie lange hält der hält der länger als
diese sechs Tage diese Woche das fragen
wir Tanja mai unsere
bildunterhaltungschefin grüß Dich
herzlich heute früh hier bei Bild live
Tanja ja wie lange hält er der 6 Tage
Frieden also ich traue Prinz Harry und
Meghan kein bisschen und natürlich für
die beiden ist es jetzt die beste PR
muss man leider sagen die Großmutter ist
gestorben natürlich sie sind jetzt
wieder im Inner Circle drin obwohl sie
ja bewusst ausgetreten sind dass der
königlichen Familie aber ich denke mal
wenn diese Feierlichkeiten vorbei sind
am Montag also mit dem Staatsbegräbnis
der Queen ihrer Prinz Harry ist
Großmutter dann werden die natürlich
nach Amerika zurückkehren und dann
werden die genauso weitermachen wie die
ganze Zeit und Prinz Harry hat ja
angekündigt dass er im November wie
geplant seine Biografie veröffentlichen
möchte also deswegen kann ich auch die
königliche Familie verstehen dass sie
natürlich alle so auf halb acht und halb
acht Stellungen sind natürlich weil man
bei den beiden eben nie weiß was es
jetzt schon wieder der nächste Schritt
weil sie denken einfach nur an sich und
ich finde selbst bei der Trauerfeier
gestern wie Meghan sich inszeniert der
Gesichtsausdruck auch dieses ewige
Händchen halten was die anderen nolz ja
gar nicht dürfen also nach dem Protokoll
William und und Kate können gar nicht
Händchen halten das sind Erwachsene
Royals wie gesagt der Thronfolger und
Meghan und Harry inszenieren sich ja
auch da schon wieder so wir beide halten
zusammen gegen den Rest dieser Familie
was ich überraschend finde ich offenbar
reicht es jetzt vor allem Kate und sie
war ja eigentlich die Brückenbauerin
zwischen den beiden Brüdern sie hat
Meghan so heißt es ganz oft die Hand
gereicht hat wirklich versucht dass
diese Fett vor dass das ganze klappt
dass diese neue Generation Royals
zusammenhält und es scheint so dass sie
jetzt der Kompass irgendwie ist in
dieser ganzen Geschichte dass er jetzt
selbst Kate sonst ausgleichend um
Frieden und Harmonie bemüht das ist
jetzt irgendwie einfach reicht ich denke
diese ganze Familie weil Meghan wurde ja
mit offenen Armen aufgenommen das muss
man wirklich sagen Prinz Charles damals
jetzt heute der König hat sie ja sogar
zum Altar geführt weil sie ja mit ihrem
eigenen Vater gebrochen hatte Meghan
also diese Frau wurde mit offenen Armen
aufgenommen und sie hat wirklich
geschafft alle gegen sich aufzubringen
jeden Einzelnen zu enttäuschen die
einzigen Personen über die sie ja nie
schlecht geredet hat waren ja die
Königin und Prinz Philip die beiden
standen über allem aber auch William und
Kate die ja wirklich sehr sehr eng waren
mit Prinz Harry also die waren ja eine
Einheit die drei und auch mit Prinz
Charles dem heutigen König sie hat es
wirklich geschafft über jeden
herzuziehen über jeder ein böses Wort zu
verlieren und natürlich wissen die ganze
Familie auch Kate und William die wissen
jetzt nicht was passiert jetzt als
nächstes wieder und das stelle ich mir
sehr anstrengend vor du musst trauern du
willst trauern du bist jetzt aber in der
Thronfolge auch noch mal einen Schritt
nach oben gerutscht also William und
Kate Prince und Princess of Wales das
heißt die sind jetzt theoretisch wenn
der König morgen tot umfällt ist William
der nächste König also die Last wird
jetzt immer noch größer die auf diesen
beiden lastet und dann haben die noch
die Verwandtschaft aus Amerika die sie
ja auch jetzt irgendwie noch unter einen
Hut bringen müssen und einfach immer
gucken müssen dass Meghan und Harry eben
einigermaßen jetzt in der Spur bleiben
sagt unsere unterhaltungschefin Tanja
mai über diesen sechs Tage Frieden in
der Royal Family danke dir
[Musik]